In 2021, Gabriel Boric became
the elected President of Chile.
He was one of the youngest worldwide
and one of the most voted
in the country's history.
He was supported by a political party
called Convergencia Social.
And by the time of the election,
I was in charge of the feminist
front of that party.
So even though I was very confident
our candidate was going to win,
the night itself of the election
was still very overwhelming,
especially so when we got to walk
through the crowds, held by security.
You know, it suddenly all felt so real
because we were walking to a stage
in front of where thousands of people
had gathered to celebrate the victory.
Because Gabriel Boric was not
just a candidate I was supporting,
he was also my partner.
So soon enough,
this meant for people that I was
about to become a First Lady.
And now I come to you,
this great audience,
and want to ask you,
have you ever thought
of becoming a First Lady?
Is it something you thought of
growing up or lately, I don't know?
(Laughter)
Well, I didn't think so.
Me neither.
Until I was about to become one.
Because really, whatever
your partner does, you know,
do you picture yourself
getting up in the morning
and accompanying him or her
to his or her job?
(Laughter)
You know?
And now picture that job
being to rule over a country.
(Laughter)
But as much as it comes
as a surprise to me,
imagine what a surprise it might be
to the voters that don't elect you.
They elected the president, right?
And the president chose me,
but surely not thinking of me
becoming an authority one day.
And so I first rejected the idea
of becoming a First Lady,
and all of, you know, what that meant.
And so, many people criticized me,
but many feminists applauded me, right.
Because, as a feminist,
I can see that feminist beliefs
seem contradictory or incompatible
with being a First Lady.
On the one hand,
OK, what does a feminist
possibly want to do
in such a conservative space?
But on the other hand,
ain't the pursuit
of taking feminist action,
even more so in such an unlikely place,
something that is worth doing
more than caring about your
coherent image as a feminist?
So I decided to meet up
with former First Ladies
of the last decades
and talk to them about their achievements,
about their experiences.
So I talked to them,
and that was very important.
It was crucial.
And I also made meetings with feminists
from different generations
to talk it all through.
But the point and the moment
that really struck me
was my meetings with attorneys,
because they told me the following.
They were like, "Well,
this is great for you.
You will have so many opportunities
and the chance to do whatever
you want with your interests."
And I was like, this doesn't sound right.
You know, he was like, "Yes,
because you can create projects,
you can create new foundations,
because this is not regulated
and there are many gray zones."
(Laughter)
I realized what this
construction was all about.
In Chile, First Lady's institutionalized
version looks like this,
because they got progressively
more and more functions, alright?
So they are anchored in the state
through diverse set of things.
On the one hand,
you've got foundations,
a set of foundations,
for example, for childhood education.
Then you’ve got a foundation
for recycling computers.
for empowering women.
Then you've got a museum
with a focus on interactive approach.
Then you’ve got education and music.
But they were all formed
by former First Ladies.
And you get to preside
[over] all of these foundations,
regardless of your
professional background.
(Laughter)
And through them, you can do your projects
or make more foundations, right?
(Laughter)
And then you've got protocol, OK?
Protocol is accompanying the president
to several events,
ceremonies, engagements.
And then you've got
something very important.
Or at least I find it very important
because it's so symbolic.
They give you an office right inside
of the presidential palace.
But it's not just an office,
it's the most beautiful one.
Like, people actually
call it Versailles, OK?
And you get to choose a team,
which I would publicly like to thank.
And so I decided to make a plan.
And my approach would be
to tackle both issues,
the democratic illegitimacy
of having the institution of marriage
so embedded in state,
and on the other hand, you know --
(Laughter)
the gender-biased imaginary
around this figure, OK?
But this meant making a turn again,
towards action this time,
because I thought, OK, on the one hand,
if I do nothing, if I don't take the job,
nothing will change.
If I do take the job,
at least I have the chance
to change something.
And we all know how traditions work.
They repeat in time until something
or someone interrupts it.
So this meant making
a new press conference
where I would say
that I was to take office
in order to transform
the figure of First Ladies.
Of course, I got criticism again,
and a lot of people actually
didn't understand this.
But something a bit painful
was, of course,
that many feminists criticized me too.
So in that criticism,
you know, is bad press
when you come from a feminist party
or a progressive party, for sure.
But while it was super uncomfortable
and I knew I was going to be,
I was very convinced
that I should use my power this way.
That's what I felt, at least.
So I started presiding
[over] the existing foundations.
So I wanted to know
if they were still, you know,
following their social goals.
And in order to have that diagnosed,
I talked to the unions, to the workers,
I wanted to understand
if they still felt valued,
if they still felt that they
were taken, you know,
into account as professionals
or if, you know,
politics were making
something else out of them.
And I talked to them. I improved salaries.
I, you know, I made job listings public.
We made processes more transparent.
And we also tried to make
standards higher in general.
So after all of this was done,
we were ready for the next step,
which was
the First Lady not presiding
over these foundations anymore.
(Laughter)
So ...
Now you've got the ministries
making the decision.
So, for instance,
now that we do have
a Ministry for Women and Equality,
she decides who will be the president
of the foundation about empowerment
for women, right?
The Minister of Education
is the one who decides
who will be the president
of the foundation for childhood education.
Makes sense, right?
All these changes took about nine months.
Now I'm just me.
I have no team, no office,
and no official role.
I don't take any resources from state.
And I still have a lot of public exposure,
and I would still attend meaningful
events with my partner.
Which brings me to the next
issue I wanted to tackle,
which is gender stereotypes, right?
Because it turns out we actually
still look at masculine authorities
as people that need to be complemented
by a feminine other.
But if you think about a woman
that has just been elected,
or a woman in power,
we expect her to have
both male and female qualities.
So this not only tells you
that relationships in such high rank,
like in a visible platform,
are expected to be
heteronormative and traditional,
but it also tells you how embedded
marriage is in state.
Turns out it was very normal
to have the wife around.
So I thought
this kind of condescending constellation
around the president
is something that will
not be well-received
from the new generations of politicians.
Because if you think about it,
women accompanying presidents
are still seen as assets.
They are seen as someone who gives
the president an image of more stability,
of completeness and of balance.
But that is because of our
accustomed view of duality.
And I think we were already past that.
I mean, church and state,
state and love,
state and marriage.
Doesn't it sound antiquated already
when you say it out loud?
When it comes to women in politics,
yes, of course we want
as many as possible.
But the good news is,
we can vote for them, right?
(Laughter)
(Cheers and applause)
Yeah.
I say we keep marriage out
of the presidential must-haves
and legitimize the person we vote for.
My goal for taking on the institutional
side of First Lady was to make change.
To take away power from a position
that is a result of affection
and not of democratic process.
Some people may think
that this is a personal
rejection of a privilege.
Instead, it's a political
rejection of power
from where it doesn't belong.
I am not to have --
(Applause)
Thank you.
I am not to have power
that people have not given me.
So I see state innovations as crucial
to turn the game around
when it comes to the devaluation
of our democracies.
Because when you think about it,
making changes
in governmental institutions,
updating them, making them
more legit again,
and taking away parts
that don't represent
contemporary needs anymore
might make people feel
more close, more reflected
in the instrument of democracies.
And that's what it's there for.
So if making symbolic, cultural
and institutional changes
increases our attachment
to democratic values,
then I say it's worth a try.
Thank you very much.
(Applause)